Europe is facing the worst financial
crisis in a generation it all started in
2007 in the United States where
over-optimistic banks went bankrupt as a
result of bad lending in the mortgage
market in September 2008 the
fourth-largest American investment bank
Lehman Brothers collapsed the crisis has
since spread to the rest of the world a
vicious circle developed banks stopped
lending to each other and credit dried
up to prevent a complete collapse of the
banking system European governments came
to the rescue of their banks with urgent
support on an unprecedented scale four
point five trillion euros the equivalent
of 37 percent of the EU s annual GDP
were committed between 2008 and 2011 the
EU also launched a europe-wide recovery
programme to safeguard jobs and social
protection levels and to support
economic investment in this way bank
runs were avoided and European savings
were protected the Euro broadly
maintained its value and successfully
shielded eurozone countries from the
worst effects of the economic crisis by
providing EU companies with a stable
playing field for international trade
and investment but this effort took its
toll especially since most of the money
had to be borrowed from late 2009 the
most exposed eurozone countries began to
have problems financing their debts
leading to a new development in the
crisis the sovereign debt crisis with
increasing deficits and spiraling debt
the markets lost confidence in certain
government's ability to pay back what
they owed
interest rates for their government
bonds soon became unsustainable
and since many of these bonds were held
by other European countries and their
banks this turned into a problem for us
all this was especially true for those
countries sharing the euro as their
currency this loss of confidence led the
banks to reduce their lending to
businesses and private households in
2009 the EU economy suffered its worst
recession since its creation after a
brief recovery it went into a mild
recession again in early 2012 as a
result unemployment reached
unprecedented levels in many parts of
Europe creating hardship and increasing
poverty levels so does that mean that
the euro made the crisis worse no not
all eurozone countries built up
excessive debts and not all countries
outside the eurozone kept their debt
under control being in the eurozone
meant that its members could count on
the Solidarity about the members because
eurozone economies are so interdependent
if one prospers others will benefit if
one falters others will suffer
that's why European leaders decided to
step up common action the key lesson of
the crisis was that Europe needed to
build a closer economic union to
complement its existing monetary union
and to ensure that public finances are
sustainable first the EU introduced new
stronger rules to keep a tighter check
on public debt and deficits to make sure
countries don't spend beyond their means
a new fiscal treaty was also signed to
further strengthen confidence limiting
yearly structural deficits to not 0.5
percent of the GDP this crisis clearly
shows that a debt fueled economy is not
sustainable the European Commission will
now make sure that the limits on debt
and deficits are applied and that
national budgets do not put at risk
other European economies this is the
purpose of a fiscal you
second European Financial Supervision is
being stepped up to ensure that banks
are better capitalized behave
responsibly and are able to lend money
to households and businesses this paves
the way for a banking Union to make sure
that people's deposits are protected and
taxpayers are not forced to pay for the
failure of banks third firewalls to
protect the single currency being
reinforced through the European
Stability Mechanism a fund that will
help eurozone countries that are
temporarily unable to borrow money on
the financial markets or require support
for recapitalization of fragile banks
loans will be provided if countries
agree to reform their economies and
restore their financial stability fourth
the European Union will pursue the
objectives of the Europe 2020 strategy
implementing structural reforms to tap
Europe's jobs potential to boost
productivity and competitiveness this
implies targeted investments using EU
and national funds to sustain
cutting-edge research spread innovation
and latest technologies connect up
Europe's transport and energy grids and
bring high-speed Internet to all
Europeans wherever they live restoring
economic growth is no easy task but we
are working together to deliver lasting
solutions to the crisis
we need sound public finances across
Europe and solidarity mechanisms for
crisis situations a fiscal union we need
stronger supervision of the financial
markets a banking Union we need a deeper
economic union with targeted investment
to boost growth and competitiveness the
European Union is a people's project
anchored in democracy and accountable to
voters it must emerge from this crisis
stronger and more United than ever a
true political union with a reinforced
European Parliament a prosperous home
for its 500 million citizens and a
strong player in the world